when toilet paper flew off the shelves
in 2020 desperate shoppers grabbed
whatever they could find in stores
including tissue made out of stuff like
bamboo i don't know it looks pretty soft
to me
if someone gave me this i don't think i
would be able to tell the difference
two years later it's still selling
why well bamboo is finally becoming as
soft as the real thing giving players in
the space a real boost
[Music]
let's do it together it is tree free it
is made from bamboo isn't that nice
this isn't normally where i put it too
we went
you know from 230 000 revenue in 2017 as
like kind of like a startup and by the
end of 2020 we had grown to around two
and a half million almost overnight we
um had enough orders we could have sold
out our warehouse kind of several
several times over
toilet paper sold as sustainable isn't
new
recycled bath tissue has been around
four decades but it has fallen short of
the softness americans expect we want to
make sure that our customers don't feel
like they're making a sacrifice
when they're switching the cloud paper
enter bamboo
manufacturers are pitching us on the
idea that toilet paper made from trees
is bad for the environment but that's
not all
bamboo has longer fibers and consumers
like that it makes for softer tissue
paper than recycled it's been a long
journey for bamboo toilet paper some
manufacturers have created dozens of
versions of the product to make sure it
was exactly what consumers wanted
also keeping prices competitive with
traditional options is key because big
brands can easily outspend them on
advertising and startups can always lose
clients that just switch back to toilet
paper made from trees
we're
in a commodity market so there's a lot
of price sensitivity and tree-free fiber
has historically been quite expensive
startups are also leaning on emotion and
creativity including cheeky commercials
deep in the downstairs bathroom maggie's
making the world a better place with her
toilet paper moreover many roles come
packaged individually in wrapping that
is colorful and artsy which has led some
people to display them openly in their
bathrooms and even post pictures of them
on social media today these companies
make up a tiny sliver of the market but
they're looking to show that the
business is viable which could help
prove to bigger brands that making tree
free toilet paper is worth it
kimberly clark which is one of the
largest toilet paper makers in the world
launched a bamboo bath tissue in
australia in 2021 i believe that there's
tremendous opportunity because
forests are finite we have to find a
better solution
[Music]